hello and welcome to the shoe sign shoe
worth today you're going to get cultured
in cell culture so to be more specific
this video will look at some tips that
are useful for trainers or beginners in
cell culture and it'll be more about
good practice as opposed the technique
since techniques and cell culture can
only really be done in person and my
drawing talent is just look good enough
to sketch it out for you and a positive
this channel really is dedicated to me
sharing lessons that I've learned from
others in attempt to help to try and
remember these lessons myself but also
to spread this knowledge that obviously
could be useful to you as well and this
video is also to try and explain the
mysterious concept of what someone's
actually doing when they say they're
splitting ourselves or changing media
without getting strange looks from
friends ok then so what actually is cell
culture well according to the definition
that I found cell culture is the process
by which cells are grown under
controlled conditions which generally
means outside of their natural
environment so it's the ability to
maintain cells of interest that may have
been isolated from actual living tissue
under carefully controlled conditions
and there's actually for a detailed a
camellia page that there's so much
detail it's all you could ever want to
know about our culture so as promised
here are some tips to get you cultured
and cell culture so the first tip is how
to freeze down your cells tactically so
the thing with cells is is that the
grave and then they divide and so if you
start with a certain amount of cells to
begin with you're gonna have more cells
at the ends and so the X ourselves can
be frozen down to be used at a later
point but doing this is actually really
important but how often and when should
I freeze down my cells you are often
advised to freeze down cells with a low
passage number and this isn't bad advice
the longer you gray cells the more time
they have had to accumulate mutations
which means the cells aren't quite the
same as how we started with now while
she might be able to shrug off this
piece of information it has important
value because an experiment you do with
the cells you
at the beginning of let's say your PhD
could be completely different to the
results she gets using the same cells at
the end of your PhD so how do you get
around this issue well as I've drawn up
here
one thing you can do is freeze down ten
to twenty or even more than twenty
different files and do this at very
early passages when you first start with
a new cell line so when you finish your
experiment she bless you throw these
other cells away and just get a file
that you freesound months ago and off
you go so there were the reason you'd
want to do something like this is that
the reproducibility of your data and
your experiments is really good well
it's better than what it would be if you
started with cells about it had gone
through multiple passages and gained
many different mutations and so this
ideas are often referred to you as your
working cell bank so for the second tip
cells come in all different shapes and
sizes and some with genetic
modifications such that looking at them
under a microscope will not be
sufficient fuses distinguish between two
different cell lines so how do you know
if the cells that you're working with
are actually the cells that you think
you're working with well you should
somewhat regularly do an STR analysis
and so STR stands for short tandem
repeats and it's a kind of like a
forensic detective DNA based methods to
determine what cells you're actually
working with another thing you should do
even more frequently is to check for
mycoplasma so my cou plasma are bacteria
that can contaminate your samples and so
my ku plasma rests on the outside
surface of cells and they can alter the
cells behavior in which case how do you
know if you have contaminated cells that
your results are what the cell would
normally do or due to the mycoplasma
affecting the cell life so tip four and
speaking of contamination one good rule
to follow is when in doubt just just do
it again if you you know maybe you
touched the surface with your tip your
strep out just just get another one
it's might seem useful sometimes but the
the waste and the cost involved in the
long run one one tip compared to a
contaminated set of cells one is
evidently much cheaper and less
time-consuming so you know with time
being the money currency in science just
is just you know being more cautious
than in other situations all right so my
next tip is beware of the bubbles now
not those thought bubbles but bubbles
that you can get from aspirating that a
little bit too fast now this is honestly
much easier said than done but the key
point here is that your cells can get
trapped in the bubbles and we don't
wanna lose ourselves all right so
another lesson / tip is to remember the
fact that everything that you do to your
cells is going to act as a selection
pressure so whether that's you know
during your centrifugation to collect
yourselves whether it's how resistant
your cells are to trypsin how vigorous
you are with the aspirating some cells
will be able to tolerate it more than
others in which case over time you will
effectively be selecting for a subset of
the cells that you initially started
with hence like similarly to the idea
that you shouldn't be working with high
passage number cells as that cells are
going to changed open or evolve you know
natural selection in the culture dish
and raining out that's cool with natural
artificial culture selection yeah that's
a thing but it's just something to bear
in mind and to keep it the forefront of
your mind and to lastly to break the
myth that cells grow faster at the
weekend this is due to the fact that
being at the back of the incubator is
better for yourselves because they're
less affected by the door constantly
being Athens and clothes so at the
weekend when in 30 less people are there
that's lots of debate and it's also open
less often in which case your house is
you know they're gonna grow out of one
of the fast ball faster rates relatively
a relatively fast rate uh-huh yeah so
that concludes my
forgetting culture and cell culture so
you know as culture dad I am hopefully
so let's take off our blue or green
colored capes for tonight and remember
when in doubt get the ethanol and as
always thanks for listening